the preeminent computer vision scientist
in fact if in your own institution you
know some computer vision people chances
are they're either jitendra students or
students or students or students of
students or students uh myself included
uh and uh so jatendra uh is uh has been
you know working on vision for for a
very long time and recently he's thought
ah Vision too easy
let's do the real hard stuff is Robotics
and so today he will tell us about about
how how language is not enough and even
vision is not enough
okay so uh let me start so since llms
have been advocated as solutions to AGI
and I find the term AGI itself are very
problematic concept which will become
clearer later
uh let's start by understanding
something about artificial intelligence
before we understand artificial
intelligence let's understand natural
intelligence and natural intelligence is
a biological construct and everything in
biology only makes sense in the context
of evolution
so the beginnings of intelligence are
like 540 million years ago in the
Cambrian explosion which is when you
have the first multicellular animals and
these animals could see and they could
move and this these two abilities go
together because the ability to move
means that you can get food in different
places
but then you need to know where to go
which means that you need some form of
perception so this is a loop perception
and motion together and there are
zillions of books on this theme that
this is what's part of uh evolution in a
very big way so I have a variety of the
file are developed and there's a line
from Gibson we see in order to move and
we move in order to see so one little
example
predator and prey relationship cause a
evolutionary answers and and that's very
related to this right so if there's a
prey they will evolve camouflage a
predator will try to detect the prey in
spite of the camouflage the prey will
try to move away then the Predator has
to move faster to to to catch the prey
and so on and so forth
okay there's a very long history there
which I will not recap but if you move
to the hominid line something like the
last five
seven million years ago you have the
development of bipedalism instead of
four legs we were walking on two legs
and our hands were free which enabled
tool making
and uh and that
is a there's an interesting story there
which is that the development of the
brain follows the development of the
hand because that with the hand you
could make tools which gave an incentive
for sort of problem solving and uh and
and modifying your environment in
various ways
and I don't mean to imply that this is
the only branch of intelligence there
are the octopus is an equally valid
branch of intelligence and many others
their evolution should not be thought of
as in this sense of scale of nature that
there is one line where it culminates
with humans above whom there are angels
and above whom there is God okay this is
this is nonsense it's really like a bush
spreading out in many different
directions
anyway in the human line in the last uh
you have the modern humans Coming Out of
Africa somewhere around there and then
they very likely already had language
and symbolic thinking so if you think of
evolution and the development of
intelligence as spanning 24 hours
language the last
one or two or three minutes of that okay
so therefore there has to that has to
just instinctively make you cautious of
a theory which says that all of
intelligence resides in those last two
or three minutes
there are continuity arguments that you
can make here right and actually there
was a slide in the previous talk sort of
in the beginning which said that
language is an ability which humans have
it's uniquely human but
it comes in the context of all these
other abilities which are pretty similar
between us and primates and and
everybody else the brain of a primate
the visual area the motor cortex they're
very similar to what what we have they
are in the same places similar structure
etc etc all these findings were done
initially on primates and then recap
repeated on humans
so that's that's the core of my argument
so
in
okay now let's contrast this with this
fact that we have had incredible success
with large language models right and it
you can't open the newspaper without
reading all about this
and what I want to contrast this with
this
uh is uh is that we there are certain
abilities we still don't have I mean we
kind of are we kind of have it I mean
maybe in a couple of years it'll be
there but we have had this enough you
know this is a Elon Musk quote from 2019
that we will have million taxis in the
next year and so on the the short
summary I would say is that the ability
self-driving cars which a 16 year old
can do in like 20 hours of training
right that has proved to be very very
hard for machines to recapitulate
whereas the law exam right the law exam
is at at the 90 percent
so there's something which is jarring
about this and let me make it even more
extreme
so here's a set of tasks I picked
there's a set of verbs which correspond
to activities that you can do in a
kitchen and a 12 year old can probably
do all of these
okay and no robot can today no single
robot can do all of these tasks
and this is of course well known in AI
uh not but somehow surprisingly not in
the popular media I do not read all
these articles that I read in the New
York Times and Washington Post they do
not talk about this in the AI literature
this is called moravex Paradox and
moravex said it in a certain way which
is it's comparatively easy to make
computers exhibit adult level
performance on intelligence test or
playing checkers but difficult to have
the skills of a one-year-old
because Pinker
does say everything more bitly the hard
problems are easy and the easy problems
are hard okay and the gardeners
receptionists and cooks are secure in
their jobs for days to come for years
decades to come
so I believe this to be true
and uh but now we need to get in a bit
underneath what does this mean why is
this
and uh morovic's argument I I think was
slightly flawed morovic's original
argument was that what we have what we
are trying to do in AI is reverse
engineering
and if we are trying to reverse engineer
then the abilities which are much older
in evolution will be harder to reverse
engineer
and that is a valid description of the
Paradigm as existed you know decades ago
but that's not the Paradigm today the
Paradigm today is that we are not
relying on our Ingenuity we are relying
on data the data has the Ingenuity so
therefore the question must be about
what data is available
and it is a data that we find that
language sort of uh the language folks
like my friends here like Chris Manning
and the agent they have lucked out
because all of language so much of
language is available on the web right
every everything is has been put up on
the web and then it's you can you know
everything from Reddit and uh you know
books and uh
everything Wikipedia it's all there and
so you can start from that now if you
think about the sensory motor experience
the equivalent of that is
uploading what when I go about my daily
activity
I I see something
I it activate and I some muscles are
activated so the right counterpart would
be my sensory motor record uploaded to
the web
and for all of humanity if we had that
then we would have the kind of
counterpart of this data but this is not
feasible this is not happening right we
will you would never consent to that in
any case
so
everybody question huh
YouTube has a part of the data YouTube
has the the some it doesn't give you the
full sensory motor experience because
you might you you see but you do not
know the the muscle activations for
example of the people
fair enough yeah but but a bigger part
is missing I would argue okay but anyway
we can debate that yeah
so uh so so anyway I will argue that the
available digitized data on the web is
is largely missing and uh so anyway
that's one remark uh then uh
then I want to get into a little bit
into Robotics and what makes robotics
hard because it's not the same way in
which other tasks are hard so this is a
robot which we have which we build in
our group and uh here it is on in a
rocky area and this is uh the this is
this on and it's a blind robot by the
way
and more examples
and now of course you will say that this
this is uh you'll see you've seen lots
of examples of this from the Boston
Dynamics people who upload YouTube
videos but what is not said is that they
design specific controllers for
situations so One controller for
climbing stairs and another controller
for descending stairs for example I I
maybe literally be wrong on that but in
in general the the that's the style
and uh whereas uh here everything that
I've shown you corresponds to one policy
in all situations and it's a blind robot
so I want to use this to make some
historical remarks but first let's think
about pattern recognition versus control
theory so pattern recognition
uh was a kind of this area which was in
the 1950s equally prominent as symbolic
AI then what happened is that symbolic
AI took off at least in computer science
departments and patent recognition was
the the poor cousin hanging around in E
departments and start departments by and
large but what they emphasized was
generalization as the central problem in
control you need what is generalization
you need two things you need robustness
to disturbances and you need adaptation
to varying physical conditions so this
adaptation is a counterpart of
generalization you need the robot to
walk in all these different conditions
and and an example of that is that in
this picture where there is one policy
which walks in all of these situations
okay
another historical remark the
1950s and wherever a very fervent period
right for lots lots and lots of stuff
happened because it's like the post-war
uh computers emerged there was a lot of
interdisciplinary communication because
in during World War II teams were set up
which were interdisciplinary in nature
so you had essentially many of these
ideas which are from the late 50s or
early 60s and there is I I haven't
listed sort of symbolic AI where they
asserted certain Theses which have
turned out to be I think quite misguided
for example the symbol system hypothesis
of Noel and Simon you should read Newell
and Simon's touring award lecture which
if you read today in the light of what
we know about word to wake and so on it
just seems wrong whereas when I was a
kid when I read it I said oh of course
they are right and that was the the
logic which led down that path of of uh
classical AI the control theory people
never believe in this control theory
people believe in equations like that
where X is a vector and a is a matrix
now the limitation there are of course
that it's all linear because in the
linear setting you can do things
analytically and work things out
now uh what I'm talking about in the
classical framework can be seen very
easily because this is the Dynamics of a
system X is a state Vector which
captures classical in physics it's
position and momentum and stuff like
that and a is capturing the Dynamics how
how it changes over time
and uh but this is a linear story
right and this a so in a classical
control theory setup this a is a
constant which is known which is called
systems identification finding that out
and then you and then you can work out
uh work things out on paper and then
implement it on a computer and this is
great this is what took man to the moon
the Apollo Mission would have failed if
you didn't have the ability to stabilize
trajectories and so forth but today what
we can do with deep learning is that we
can just
do everything allow everything to be
non-linear
which is a very very big but powerful
thing and what we do is that we allow
this a also to be changing
which is what you have to do for all
this these different terrains for
example
and that's that's what deep learning
gives for gives us it takes that
classical control theory way of thinking
and combines it with this power of uh
what we have to do is combine that with
the power of deep learning
Okay so
so now I'll I'll take you through so now
uh okay
now let's talk about big data so the
success of uh success of llms is is like
it is due to three different parts
one part are these the the the power of
SGD if you will right
one part of it is the availability of
hardware
but a very important part of it is data
which as I said I mean for language
people all the data is available on the
web so now if we want to apply that
magic
okay of sort of algorithms data and
compute then
where is the data going to come from
okay now here typically if you think
about any robotics task they they the
most natural mapping is to reinforcement
learning
sorry
so uh I mean uh in fact optimal control
there's a classical setup of optimal
control where you have a known Dynamics
and then you have some cost function
which is try which you're trying to
optimize so the cost function in the
setting might be you want to minimize
your energy and you want to walk as long
as possible right I mean this is a
typical setup and right
now uh that is actually totally
connected to reinforcement learning
because reinforcement learning is also
an optimal control setup it's just being
optimized in a different way so the
classical control theory people will
write down the model and analytically
work out the optimal solution
reinforcement learning is a way of
solving that same
for minimizing that same cost function
but using basically fancy trial and
error
Okay now what's the problem with that
the problem with that is that you takes
a very large number of Trials and when
you have a physical robot
you can't do that very large number of
Trials so what are the early successes
of RL if you see a deep mind what do
deepmind become famous for the big
success why deep learning took off I
mean for some people with success
advision but for some people with
success at go why what's so unique about
go well because you can play it in a
simulator
because you can play it in the simulator
and you can do the billion trials and
it's no problem when you do a billion
Trials of a real robot you are going to
have to deal with wear and tear and all
the rest of it and it's not going to
work so well
so so this is to me the central problem
reinforcement learning is a very natural
tool to use but reinforcement learning
given the algorithms we have today uh
when applied on physical systems is is
problematic
now this this is where we are lucky in
the context of language because the
humans manage to learn with I mean the
same is true for human learning or motor
acts as it is for language humans are
much more efficient Learners a human
baby here is maybe a million words a
month that's the estimate that I've read
which is very small so at the age of 10
uh how much would that be that would be
100 million right well
clearly our language model is attained
with much more than that so our language
models are are able to get away with
inefficiency in learning now the same we
have the same inefficiency in terms of
human babies learning versus our
machines learning but
we can't deal with that wear and tear
yeah um
very high I will that that is actually
half my talk so so from now on says
umesha asked the right question I did I
didn't set him up for this uh basically
half my talk is can we make this work in
simulation and I'll show you ways of
doing that and my the other half of my
talk is what if it's not possible to do
it in simulation then we have to try to
make a learning process more efficient
the way human learning is more efficient
and those are the two strategies and I
am thoroughly opportunistic and I'm
trying both
yeah so
so now I'll tell you the the simulation
version so this is the first half of the
talk which is so we have uh and the the
high level summary is we developed this
recipe called rapid motor adaptation and
I'll abbreviate it as RMA and this is a
trick that we have which enables us to
train in simulation and then transfer to
the real world and we have used this
trick like three or four times it's not
an algorithm but like a meta trick so
the way you can think of dynamic
programming is not a specific algorithm
but like a template with which you can
design algorithms in different settings
so this RMA is that and I'll give you
examples of that then this next half of
my talk is going to be how to learn from
data in the real world and that's where
actually there are good analogies with
counterparts of the techniques which
have been found worthwhile for language
models
so let me give you like the the two
minute version of this rmetric uh so uh
so this is what we want eventually so we
want uh so the policy the the policy is
your controller which outputs an action
a and it is given as input the state so
the state for a robot might be the joint
angles of every uh of the legs of the
robot and so on a of T minus 1 is the
action at the previous state
and uh so this is not this is some
non-linear box it's some neural network
which outputs the action which is
desired joints and so forth right this
is going to be trained in some way very
importantly there is this variable Z
and this Z is some latent which captures
the environment so are you working on
Sand are you working upstairs are you
working downstairs things like that
okay and so the idea is that you make
the policy depend not just on the state
but also on this variable Z which
captures aspects of the environment so
in a linear system this would be
complicated but in a non-linear system
this information can be used to
essentially change the equivalent of
that Matrix a because of this Z
and then the problem is that we don't
know what Z is
right
so the Z is he is by the way it's like a
low dimensional Vector for us it's like
eight dimensional or something like that
and this has to be estimated and and
this is the the clever part is this that
the Z itself can be estimated by another
uh neural network which is operating at
some meta level and the intuition is
something like this
I let's say I'm I'm walking so I I walk
so I I move my my legs and feet and so
forth and I issue a set of commands and
then there are the consequences of that
which are being sensed now if I'm
walking on hard ground
when I lift up my foot with the same
Force something happens if I'm walking
in sand I'm walking now on a beach I
lift up my foot with the same Force
something different happens it lifts up
only partially
right so that means that
how my body reacts to the same sequence
of commands reflects something about the
environment so it is revealed by by what
happens so so now you imagine that I
have if I have my temporal history a
history of states and actions over the
last so many time steps then that has
the information
which reveals what conditions you are in
and and that's what this adaptation
module does it takes that as input and
it tries to estimate the Z vector
okay so that's the intuition of how it
works what I haven't told you is the the
operationalization of this idea how do I
train this how do I train this but this
is if you will technical detail but but
that conceptual system is I think super
simple yeah
X
I have both the state of the environment
and the robot so X is what you can sense
from the robot so it's in this case it
is joint angles
yeah
the x is what is known X is exactly what
you know the C is the part that is yeah
so so there are alternative ways of
thinking about this right so there is so
another way you could do is to put x and
z together into some new X Prime and
then you would set up the problem as a
partially observable markup decision
process and so on that those methods
will end up being totally intractable
form DPS is an area which the wise thing
is don't go there okay
okay then you would know what the right
action to do is so that's yeah or the
base the Baseline is human so human
knows the environment knows this lady
they're in and yeah I mean the human may
not consciously know it but implicitly
you know yeah in the sense that the next
step I make that's the right step and
you're trying to
get to that correct correct yeah so this
so essentially you can think of it as a
fully observable situation where you
would know the Z and we we can create we
actually train in simulation with that
and then we train a separate estimator
for estimating Z and that's not going to
be perfect it's going to be noisy
it's not going to be the exact ground
truth but assuming suitable continuity
conditions if it's approximately right
the policy will be approximately right
and always you are measuring and then
you are in a feedback loop so therefore
you can always correct for any error
yeah I mean the adaptation model
internally always knows Z because it's a
recurrent Network yeah
okay and and that's it uh by the way
this is this is uh so we have this this
thing we came up with uh you know a
couple of years ago and now we have
milked it in different settings
and uh so the the basic setup so here's
a by the way a little example so this is
uh
uh so this is uh uh okay this is Ashish
That You Don't See but you see him
pouring olive oil this is during the
pandemic so I told him take the robot
home and work on it so he used to sleep
with the robot next to him and led to
extreme productivity okay so uh so there
is olive oil on this uh on this uh
carpet
and now this robot is going to try to
walk and he makes it actually hard by
putting some plastic on the socks and
the robot and then the robot tries to
walk
okay
so what did you see you should see it
sort of suffering a little bit let's do
it in slo-mo
okay so now let's describe this so what
happened was it was it had parameters
corresponding to walking on hard ground
it starts to work on the slippery thing
so some friction coefficients are
different and now what's happened is
that it's so it's messed up it's not
able to work and if it continued like
that it would fall but what so what's
happened is in our language the Z has
changed
and and what has to happen is that the
estimator for Z has somehow got to get
the new estimate of Z and once the new
estimate of V is fed into the policy the
right things will happen
and let's see what happens here so here
you will see it working and so Z is an H
dimensional Vector but Z1 and Z5 are are
shown here and what you and at the top
you have sort of a right rear front left
and so on so those correspond to which
legs of the robot are on the ground and
as the robot moves you will see uh
you'll see what's happening so it's uh
so it's tumbling
and then because it has the wrong Z
values and then once the Z values are
estimated to be correct then the policy
changes and it can it can work
okay
and uh
okay and then uh okay fine this this
example is clear I want to tell you
something which I like about
reinforcement learning which I which I I
think are these are arguments that the
deepmind people used to make and uh and
which is different from the the benefits
of just generic uh supervised learning
which is the ability to discover things
that
the the people hadn't thought of okay so
emergence and now emergence is a very
fraught term but in reinforcement
learning what happens is that you're
doing a lot of trial and error
under some rules of the game but with
that trial and error strategies can
emerge that a human player may not have
thought of I mean that's been true in go
and so forth but in this setting like
the the if if your Boston Dynamics
designing a controller you would design
a controller for a robot for walking
versus trotting versus galloping each of
them would have a separate control law
because the differential equations which
govern the Dynamics change depending on
the nature of contact
in this case what we do is we just
specify a term in the loss function
which says uh
uh this is the desired speed at which
you go so when the desired speed is
relatively low 0.375 meters per second
this is the gate that emerges
okay
okay and then
sorry
that should and let's keep playing that
increase the volume
okay and now if I say give it a more
desert higher desired speed
then if you notice the footfall pattern
has changed
okay
I did not program this in I mean all the
robot is told is conserve energy and
move forward
and then if you give it a even higher
desired velocity than these different
speeds
this I would count as a genuine
emergence phenomena and it is a simple
explanation for it energetics and these
people in biomechanics knew at low
speeds walking is more energy efficient
at high speeds running is more efficient
for a horse you have a variety of gates
and and these curves sort of basically
say that and that's what you get
okay so let's continue with this
template of walking so far I've did
blind working and blind people can walk
perfectly well so that's why you must
start with that but what do you need
vision for okay if I have to cross a
river on Stepping Stones I better have
uh is he good to have have vision and
then of course in more difficult
conditions like stairs and so forth
and uh and so this is uh this is another
paper which is going to try to use that
same template
okay and here is the idea so now we have
our robot and it's got a camera on top
and this camera sees the depth in front
of it and that's the image of the depth
in front of it and we are trying to
train a policy for it
and this policy is going to have some Z
which is a measure of the environment
and then this gamma this gamma is some
measure of the geometry of the
environment in front of it so again the
geometry you do not need a detailed
geometry everywhere what you want to do
is to compress the geometry into the
most into a relatively small vector and
that Vector is gamma gamma for G for
geometry right and uh which come okay
and basically now you have these two
related vectors which capture one which
is capturing things like friction and so
forth and one which is capturing things
like some aspect of the geometry
and uh and then let's and that's and and
again I'm skipping the details
underneath the hood but the high level
story is quite simple
and and now this is uh this is what uh
this is what we can do
so there's a camera on top of it this is
what the camera sees and it knows
nothing about the environment so the
environment is is uh is you just put
some obstacles in front of it or these
tools and it has to work
so as you can see it is uh ashish's
apartment
this is yeah
and and uh so one thing with worth
commenting on uh because sometimes
people do this by imitation of human
movement patterns that wouldn't work
because the steps are actually quite
high for the for this essentially this
dog right and uh so the strategy
develops is one where it's sort of the
rear leg is sort of put out to the right
kind of like hurdles when you see humans
running hurdles there's a aspect of this
so the
so here it's suffering but it manages to
make it
okay and then this is in uh in at CMU
because we wanted to prove that it
didn't work only in work life
[Laughter]
okay
okay uh anyways so so this is the
okay I'm good okay so now uh I I want to
show where this uh so what are the
hidden assumptions here so basically is
robotics or can I just turn the crank on
this no it's not and the pro the
challenge here is we need to build
scraters which are good enough
and that has proved to be quite a
challenge
and uh the simulator doesn't have to be
perfect because uh this this adaptation
process which deals for variation from
one real world condition to another also
deals with the variation from the
simulator to the real one see for a
physicist these are all solved problems
but there are unknowns like you don't
know the friction you don't know the
characteristics of the granular medium
and so forth so in theory Newton's Laws
deal with everything but in practice uh
implementing them means that you need to
know all these parameters that you don't
know
okay so what we did was we said let's
take a task which is representative of
dexterous manipulation so dexterous
manipulation is how you can use your
hands to manipulate objects okay so like
rotating an object in the hand
okay and then this is that task
so generalization here means that you
are rotating different objects of
differing mass and so on and so forth
and this is rotation about the z-axis so
again the approaches you train in
simulation so you're training in
simulation with like a billion trials
and then after that you put it out in
the real world then these are the
results and this shows what uh what this
is
okay so there's a lot of variation
because some objects are light some are
heavy and so on and so forth
okay now this is a task that humans can
do quite well I mean it's easy but by
the way a one-year-old couldn't do it
right it takes some sketch
uh okay now we took a version of this
task which I think is hard even for
humans and this is uh try to do the task
for an arbitrary axis of rotation so
rotating about the Z axis is easy
because essentially your fingers are
holding up the object rotating about
like the x-axis of y-axis or some
arbitrary unit Vector is more
challenging because uh I mean just try
it I think if you try to rotate about X
or Y axis so Z is vertical here and X
and Y are two arbitrary direction to the
plane just try doing it yourself you'll
find that it's not easy
okay and when we did this we
interestingly what we found was so this
is that paper we found that we could not
do it blind so the previous task demos
you saw were all blind but if you do
want to do a harder task so this is a
good story which is that when you walk
an easy terrain you can you don't need
Vision but when you walk in hotel in you
need Vision here when you're trying to
do the more difficult rotation task you
need full sensing and sensing means
vision and obviously touch what you have
in your fingers
and uh and here is the the final proof
let me see if this works so here okay
there is an axis of rotation which is
listed so anyway there is a Cartesian
product here of different axes or
rotation and different objects and and
it uh it okay you can see what it does
and uh okay Machinery the details don't
matter the main point is again the same
high level template of RMA Works which
is you use your sensing to over a longer
time interval to estimate some aspects
of this Z vector and and by the way
there's a little uh
observation here that there are two
different time scales involved there is
a Time Square at which you're moving all
your joints and then there's a time
scale at which you're adapting and that
adapting is over a slower time scale and
it works because we don't fall instantly
instantaneously see if I am falling and
now let's let me do
something which I didn't expect I will
stumble and that stumble is like half a
second worth and if I can recover in
that half a second I'm okay
and that that is basically what is going
on in these things there is a fast time
scale at which you move your joints and
there is a slower time scale at which
you adapt and so long as you have that
labor you are good
okay and and there are some things which
so we get this very pretty result which
is that blind the performances like this
and this is when you have full ground
truth and just touch uh is uh just okay
one of these is just measured one of
these is just toucher this is vision and
touch
[Music]
and so on
so um
is it uh you know is it that adaptive
mechanism that you described or is it a
comes to uh to a place where it might
fall off that that it does it does best
effort or doesn't actually stop and say
well can't do it uh it it doesn't say I
can't do it because it because it's been
uh because the cost function that it has
is trying to always keep it moving the
cost function is always try to move
right is it much harder if you try to
put in a cross-function where you say
well no no that's that that's like one
layer above I haven't shown you some we
have some recent results where we we now
took the this dog and we put a strategic
Behavior like Game Theory so Pursuit
evasion games so you have one robot
which is trying to chase another robot
and then you get in more intelligent
Behavior so the best way to think about
it is that there are layers of behavior
okay
I'm not very sure to go to go listen
therefore I can ask somebody for advice
you can do that I mean that can be put
in yeah if you just didn't have that for
this experiment okay so I'll skip this
part but basically it says that it works
it that that using more senses is good
which is by the way interesting because
uh I feel that robotics is uh is a field
which is quite behind computer vision
and quite behind natural language okay I
I think I can say this even in the
presence of Robotics people it speeds
like it's 10 years behind or 20 years
behind Okay uh so my simple argument is
just look at the hardware in computer
vision I started in computer vision and
Robotics in the early 80s and my advisor
used to advise both Robotics and vision
students and the vision people we are
struggling with three images which were
like of low resolution and that's all we
had in the lab and that's all we plan
all our algorithms from and today there
are a trillion photos on the web or
maybe more okay
uh at that time the robotics people had
a robot arm and it was equipped with a
parallel jaw gripper and you go to my
colleague's lab today and they have a
robot arm which is equipped with a
parallel geographer so okay so uh now
it's not completely true because you
have some multi-fingered hands but I
believe that until you you we really do
need the right Hardware which is the
argument for embodiment so I think my
earliest first slide I was arguing that
language is kind of this disembodied
thing which in real animals or real
humans it builds on top of all this
layer of embodiment
right and anyway that is my my
uh position that
you need physical intelligence on top of
which to develop the symbolic
intelligence and if you develop a purely
symbolic linguistically based
intelligence it is a valid intelligence
right
it's fine I'm not going to go into
debates on do these llms are they
stochastic parrots or intelligence
that's a debate which is a to me no
value
but it is a certain weird alien
intelligence that's all that if I want
an intelligence which is closer to
humans because that's the kind of
intelligence that I want in my home
robot I will want it to be based on
where the
the the the linguist stability is
connected with grounding
okay now uh okay I have 20 minutes now
the second part of my talk less yeah uh
the the second part of my talk is I made
up the story using simulation and this
works for setting where you have
simulation now this is not a model for
real
uh how children learn because children
learn do not need a billion trends
now I think that in the language case
they had said who cares and just they've
gone ahead with it
I feel that that I that I I really want
to bet on uh nature I feel that the
recipe that nature evolved is actually a
good word to learn on but it was not me
who thought of this first the person who
thought of it first was actually Alan
Turing that same famous paper of 1950
which proposed the Turing test if you
take the trouble to read all the way to
section 5 or section six you have this
paragraph
instead of trying to produce a program
to simulate the adult mind why not
rather try to produce one which
simulates the child's If This Were then
subjected to an appropriate course of
Education one would obtain that
earthquake
so Turing said this then it's brilliant
it's like uh yeah but you can push it
further say instead of doing the you
know as a human child why not do uh you
know a dog or a cat child sure yeah yeah
I mean I I think that those are all
research agendas one can pursue yeah so
now the difference is so during this
paper is 1950
uh and today is 2023 the what is the
difference what has changed in the last
70 years obviously computers have got
much faster and so on but to me one very
interesting point is our colleagues in
Psychology have not been
have been active and they've they've
done a lot of research on how children
learn
and uh and and and and this is something
that we can draw on today which during
obviously would have had no idea at that
time I mean there were people like
Piaget who had already written stuff on
Child Development but basically not much
was known but
now 70 years later a lot is not for
example we know that there like this
child in the crib is interacting with
objects in a very multimodal way there
is touch there is sight there is sound
and then the the the uh Alison Alison
gothnic who's a colleague in Psychology
she has this book uh the title of which
is the scientist in the crib
and one of our points is that the kid
when the kid is you know when your
toddler is in a high chair and throwing
stuff down you shouldn't feel upset that
the the toddler is really a scientist
carrying out experiments through which
she is a building a model of the world
and these and the beauty is that this is
a controlled experiment because you
supply the controlled input and then you
get the consequences of that so you get
to build a causal model uh and then this
child when you take when when this mom
is taking the child to the zoo at the
age of two then one example of a zebra
is enough but it's because in this early
stage the child has built models of the
three-dimensional world
is build models of how objects look like
from different points of view models of
physics how do different materials
interact models of social interaction
and behavior and so on and so forth it
has a very very rich
set of capabilities
okay
and
and then there so so I mean this is a
huge literature thousands of papers have
been written on it I like this one
review paper Linda Smith and Michael
Jackson Linda Smith is a professor at
Indiana and they have tried to boil it
down to some six principles of childhood
learning
and uh one is multimodality so the use
of different uh senses all at the same
time
incremental so there are stages of
learning so here's another here's what
we know
when the child is born what does the
child look at most preferentially turns
out the child looks at faces
then after that the child looks at hands
then after that the child looks at other
objects
okay they're very very distinct stages
of sort of evolution of what the child
is interested in doing okay there's
stages in terms of motor actions the
stages in terms of language so in
language there is a stage where the Isla
the child works with triplets or you
know subject verb object kind of
triplets then
so on there is a stage when the the
words are very concrete they they're the
sensory motor programs are being learned
by trial and error
there is a state when the child goes to
school and then starts reading books and
then is essentially acquiring the
meanings or words by completing missing
words and that's a very important stage
but it is a stage which comes at the end
of this process
and when we do llms now I'm going to
philosophize for sure when we do llm
we're just totally turning this
backwards
elements are doing that last stage
without doing the early stages
and now they can do much more than what
your human does because no human reads
as much information as as is available
on the web so that's why my I want to
call it an alien intelligence
it is not a human intelligence it's an
alien intelligence and I don't want to
argue about the word intelligence
because to me an octopus has a valid
intelligence mode and uh and a crew
Crews by the way are very clever there
are all these experiments on a new
Caledonian crows solving problems
octopuses again you can read that
there's a book uh there are many books
on this octopuses are like the the new
animal uh fashionable animal to study uh
their books on cognition and animals and
in my mind there's a continuity between
animal intelligence is a human
intelligence is language is a
discontinuity
so picking language is the model of of
intelligence this is wrong there is
something just fundamentally
inept about it I'm not trying to say
language is unimportant language is very
important it's uniquely human but don't
make that the model of intelligence
because that is the one discontinuity
with respect to all the N minus one
species that we have
okay it's useful but it is not done now
let me rant on why AGI is such a stupid
term AGI is an implication and and I ADI
is an implication that there is one AGI
one unique dimension of problem solving
ability or intelligence no again if you
think about intelligence it's like a
bush or a shrub and there are many
branches which have developed so like
the octopus has like 500 million neurons
it's an amazingly intelligent character
animal with a very distributed
intelligence a lot of the intelligences
in each of the arms of the octopus okay
it's a very as opposed to a more
centralized system like us
is it not a valid intelligence it's a
valid intelligence so the term General
with intelligence
it's a wrong thing to do there are
specific intelligences the octopuses
intelligence is important the cruise
intelligence is important the humans
intelligence is important the kinds of
assistance that I want in my home would
have been built up on this kind of a
structure and then I would be in a much
more sympathetic situation with it I
will use
gpt4 it is an alien intelligence and
it's good for correcting my essays or
whatever but fine use it whichever way
you like do not put it on the pedestal
in the way mean medieval Christian
method there was a scale of nature which
started with plants actually there I I
forgot the diagram where rocks were at
the bottom and then plants then animals
then man then Angels then God okay this
is this is not the way you
should think about intelligence okay
enough of this that I've I'll use five
minutes for some other examples uh so so
now I'll show you
um uh some results which are in the
nature of how do we try to manage with
the the the the big sample complexity
limitation that you will have if you are
trying to develop intelligence with
these human constraints so the sample
complexity for a child
is is a much bigger constraint than it
is for uh computer programming
simulation
so I'll give you one example which is uh
we have this paper which is trying to do
cross motor supervision so here's this
robot and I want to make it learn to
walk using vision
but I don't want to uh to do it in
simulation
so here is a note when this robot is is
on the stairs then if I calculate from
the kinematics the the lengths of the
various legs and the joint angles and
simple trigonometry you can figure out
the heights of every point right with
the information that is accessible to
this animal
so what that says is that and and what
do I want Vision to do I want Vision to
tell me the the the depth in front of me
because I want to climb up stairs and so
on
so it turns out that what you can do is
you can
uh yeah so so here's an example of what
our system at work
so
it starts learning while walking
and first day it's not so good second
day is better and the third day is much
more
successful
so now what was the secret
okay so the secret was this so the
proprioceptive system the system of
joint angles gives me an estimate of the
depth over time right as I'm walking now
I know what my where my feet are and
what my vision system does
is is that uh I want Vision to give me a
prediction in advance one second in
advance
so what you need to do is to just take
the visual stream and the and the
proprioceptive stream just shift them in
time
and train the vision system to predict
what the proprioception will will
measure one second later so you've got
self supervision nobody you don't need
an external supervisor if one modality
is supervising the other modality and
this works basically that's what we
should and then the beauty is that you
have lifelong learning so here is this
robot and what we did was we messed up
it's it's uh its camera system
so it's going to suffer initially okay
anyway and then and then it becomes uh
okay let's see right
so it's not adapted so therefore it's
the system is messed up it's like if I
took your eyes and I rotated them by 30
degrees but as it walks it's getting the
correct data which does the calibration
okay
okay so now let's show you what happens
after one minute of training data
so this is a well-known phenomena in
humans it's called prism adaptation you
can take a prism and put it in front of
one of the eyes and all the Rays will be
deviated by 10 degrees and if you try to
reach an object you fail but you keep
doing it for a bit and you adapt
okay I'll give you another example uh so
this is
okay I'm now out of time so I'll
conclude in three minutes so this is uh
okay let's skip all this
okay so I wanted to give you a flavor or
something which is very uh llm-ish which
is uh that uh how do I train a vision
system
which will work for many tasks
and uh so that's the goal I want to do
various tasks and instead of having
a a separate Vision system for every
task I want a One Vision system for many
tasks
and uh and this is the the idea of this
paper led by India
and uh
and the idea is that we train a vision
system by a self-supervised objective
with what's called Master Auto encoder
so suppose here's an image
and what I do is I delete Patches from
the image
and then you give the computer the
remaining patches and you ask it to fill
in the rest so this is exactly the moral
equivalent of you delete a word and you
try to fill it in
so you might say oh the vision people
are learning from language but no
actually Alia shared a paper on this
like in 2015 or 2016. I will say the
language people are learning from vision
of course that's not correct because
there was this idea of the closer task
which goes back to the 50s and 60s so we
can go on forever but it's a really a
very good idea of filling in missing
words but this idea works in the context
of vision as well and with this so this
is like the
so this is a self uh self-sup
supervision via Master encoder blah blah
blah okay delete all this okay it works
okay
Second Story is can we apply this for a
robotic task and this is a very recent
paper we've just put it out on archives
so here what we do is we have a robot
and now you take the full cycle so a
robot has multiple senses and it has its
proprioception and it is trying to
perform an action
and so you've got a trajectory which has
all these aspects to it
and what you do is you delete some and
you try to fill them in from the rest
so this is the idea which is I think the
exact counterpart of what has been used
successfully in the llms and uh
and so what you have is real world
trajectories and the sensory motor
pre-training is basically the same as
the GPT task and that's why we call this
paper rpt robot pre-training
and then after that you do Downstream
tasks and uh and uh
okay so these are what the trajectories
look like
and now how do you use it for acting you
you have the sequence available up to
now and you try to fill in the action at
the next moment and that you then you
perform that and then you try to extend
it kind of in Auto regressive Style
and uh
and this uh this works it works for
simple tasks it will not work for very
complex tasks but this is what we need
to do for research for
okay I think I'll uh
I I should have some dramatic ending
slide but uh I'll leave it at that thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
so I'm no expert in language or robotics
but just a little pushback about your
thing that intelligence should be
opportunity learned from language so in
all your examples and I assume that
that's true in general you know the
robot is alone
he's not interacting with another robot
whereas uh in the language
model you could sort of think about
these different agents talking to each
other understanding what the other
person so there's something about
interaction
uh that requires intelligence I guess
and interaction seems to be better
suited to be learned through the
language at least today
yeah so I I think uh again I if I had I
deleted those slides from my talk which
is about social learning so social
learning is is very important okay and
uh social learning is mediated partially
through language and partially through
imitation so social just means learning
from other people and in humans we can
call this culture but you have that
actually in Guerrilla colonies as well
and families of prose figures out a
trick other crows figure out that trick
too by just observing
okay so I I totally agree with you that
social learning is a very big part of it
social learning has probably made more
efficient by language
I I know that I I don't want to go down
the path of saying language is useless
okay that is but I yeah I I'm certainly
using language to argue that language is
useless is a self-contradiction I am I
am merely objecting to the to language
imperialism which is what is uh which is
what is happening right now I I feel
that a language has its place language
is uniquely human but intelligence is
not uniquely human
and so
it's it's the it's the last is the
cherry on the cake or the last five
percent or if you want to call it the
last 50 I have no objection to that I I
just want to object to a theory of
language which is a theory of
intelligence which is based exclusively
on language that's what I objective
along the um um the questions that the
Shafi has erected of what there are a
lot of poachers for example using
um multimodo in language
um so do you think there is a
possibility to put
um the robotics as a sequential task and
and get some more information from the
language maybe they'll share similar
patterns yeah no so so I again I mean
the last thing which I showed was
learning from trajectories and
trajectories are one dimensional just
like language so there it it does feel
similar but the point uh and there is
work by the way the the group which has
done most of this is Google with Google
have spent a lot of time in the last
couple of years trying to show that uh
learning robotics tasks through language
and our point was to show the language
is unnecessary for that
I think language will be necessary for
the later stages of sort of high level
planning for communication with a human
and so on but basic motor tasks I mean
an ape can do it perfectly well
a crow can do it perfectly well and
octopus can do it perfectly they don't
need language a sequential solving of
physical problem solving tasks in the
world does not lead language language is
convenient for talking to other people
about it like we can uh you know uh I
can talk with yejin about the last
Mammoth hunt we had three days ago in a
displaced in space and time language is
good for that kind of stuff language is
value but a language anti-language I'm
just saying language is not the the the
the symbol of intelligence
response from the language imperialist
Corner
yeah so um whenever jitendra or aliosha
says
uh language is not as important as you
think uh I mean you uh language people
I cannot explain I love it
um but I disagree of course
um I I'm to to spice things up though I
might add that one of your Berkeley
colleagues whose name I'm not going to
mention surprised me by saying that oh
he's so excited about llms because
um it uh represents the interactive
Behavior knowledge about the world like
you know it's almost like there's a lot
of a World Knowledge backed in because
it's coming from interactive data which
I think was also what Chaffee was going
after uh in in her comment
um uh but you know I I I I I I I agree
and disagree even with that in the sense
that yes language does record the social
and interactive aspects of human lives
but on the other hand it is not the case
that llms actually learned through
interactions uh uh in the way that
humans who would have and being able to
hypothesize and experiment in the way
that Alison gopnik was pitching in her
books about how children learn as a
scientist as a philosopher on that note
though because you're going so fast the
toward the end I wasn't sure whether
your exploration in this robotics space
actually uh uh was able to touch on that
experimental aspect of human childhood
learning like you know learning about
the causality learning up learning we we
don't so there's a part of it which
actually Alicia has done this kind of
work more than I have which is that you
want to have exploration without regard
to a specific objective
and and then you want to record the
consequences of that and I believe in
that but the verse that I showed did not
have that
uh cool so I guess this might be a good
Galaxy brain but
um I wonder
um so you mentioned that implemented
simulation environment is really
important for some of these tasks and I
wonder what kind of skills do robust
assist need to implement simulating
environment and I just wonder like
whether at one point we can have large
language models to do it and in that way
we can use it alien intelligence to help
us build human intelligence faster no
this stimulation environment they are
like major engineering efforts because
the the physics is known right
theoretically this is like known 200
years ago the question is to do it fast
because we need to run a billion trials
so it's an engineering problem so the
group which is currently the dominant
group in this is NVIDIA because they
have access to the gpus they have access
to the low level uh sort of uh software
Cuda programmers and all the rest of it
so uh so there's a group led by Dita Fox
who is all so at UW who who I think the
like Isaac Jim and so on so I I quite
like that line of work it's uh I I
really to me it's a scientific question
how can we learn with a million trials
rather than a billion trials a billion
trials will make it work in simulation
like all the walking stuff a billion
trials that's a good rule of thumb
whereas for a human we have data on like
like uh uh Karen Adolf at NYU she has
actually done observations of kids
learning to walk and kids fall a lot by
the way so it's not that they learn with
zero trial and error they fall a lot but
it's not a billion times
and so I just if I can be off improve
things by factor three and ten to the
three then I think we can do learning in
the real world that's to me in the
scientific goal
all right let's thank jitendra again
[Applause]
we now Drake for lunch and we can mean
at 2 pm